there must have been so much
for you to just
sort of like dive into to to bite into
with this character to do what was the
first thing that you did when you got
the role
um well the first thing i did was like
thank andy circus because andy was the
reason why i got the role you know he
was the one who asked for me and and
i've always said like he's the nicest
person on the planet so um whatever he
asked me to do i'll do
um and then i you know i said about
preparing for the role in the same way
that i do all my roles which is um i
actually imagine a situation just like
this where i'm being interviewed um and
so i just kind of um i go through the
scripts i have all uh the clues about
who the character is and but then i fill
in like those the missing parts by doing
an interview and like imagining you know
what my character would say and then i
discovered their mannerisms their vocal
qualities their little quirks and what
makes them tick and then i just start to
put them together that way
what a cool way to do it
that's a that's a very interesting way
to get out yeah
speaking to so many like acting coaches
and so on they're like really
like that's so weird i'm like but it
works for me so
no no it totally makes sense i imagine
you know andy is such a nice guy and i
imagine on set he's the kind of guy
that's like okay let's go bigger let's
go more like is is that accurate i can
just see that sort of
that's so interesting because he's the
complete opposite of that because he's
always so truth focused so he's always
like less
less more heart centered you know yeah
that's what he's about
uh so especially with something like
this is the tendency to think
sort of because of the source material
that we want to do
all these wild things and he just goes
let's get to the core exactly exactly
that's the thing yeah because ultimately
that's what makes anything impactful
right it's not the
the
caricatures that we fall in love with
it's the heart it's the pain it's the
truth that makes us connect with the
characters
right is there uh does he have like a
phrase that he uses often
some sort of
some sort of rallying cry or even
something he might not even notice
no no i don't think there is but i just
think you know what his magic his like
superpower is that his level of
enthusiasm he's just all on your side
he's always championing you and no
matter what you're doing it's it's
incredible it's amazing it's the best
thing ever
and and that enthusiasm rubs off on you
and makes you feel like wow i'm pretty
amazing because abby thinks i'm amazing
and then you know deliver more and more
for him so that way he does it
woody has has mentioned you know that
people
love serial killers are just fascinated
by them why do you think that is
yeah that's a really good question i
don't know i think um
i don't know i think there's something
about the fact that you know it's one of
the reasons why i enjoyed playing this
character is that we don't society
really constrains us and you know makes
us uh negate our dark side but we all
have a dark side right so we but we
don't get to explore it and it's so it's
really fun when you get to explore it
and so i think that's what people are
really intrigued by you know somebody
who really flips to like the worst
possible side of humanity and exhibits
these really awful you know um
sides of humanity and they're totally
unexplored within themselves so i think
there's something fascinating about that